E-Autos für die einen sind sie viel
sicherer als Verbrenner für die anderen
sind sie rollende Brandbomben die
gefährlichen Sondermüll zurücklassen im
Internet bei Familienfeiern und in der
Mittagspause wird immer wieder hitzig
darüber diskutiert aber wer hat recht
das Thema wirkt auf den ersten Blick
vielleicht nicht unglaublich komplex
aber glaubt uns das ist es wir haben bei
der Feuerwehr einem Recycling
Unternehmen und bei diversen Behörden
und Versicherungen nachgefragt und wir
haben uns für euch die Finger wund
recherchiert und bringen euch in diesem
dr Watson video kompakt alle Fakten wie
oft brennen E-Autos wirklich stellen sie
für die Feuerwehr wirklich so ein großes
Problem da und welche falsche Zahl wird
dazu seit Jahren von allen möglichen
Medien sogar der Tagesschau immer wieder
wiederholt herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Video auf Dr
[Musik]
Wats also die erste Frage wie oft
brennen eAutos am besten sollten es ja
die wissen die die Schäden bezahlen
Versicherungen aber falsch gedacht der
GDV konnte uns nur sagen jährlich gibt
es in Deutschland ungefähr 40.000
autobränd davon ca 25 000 kleinere
schmorbränd und es gebe keinerlei
Hinweise darauf dass E-Fahrzeuge
häufiger brennen eine konkrete Statistik
dazu ist aber noch im Aufbau von einem
großen Versicherungsunternehmen bekamen
wir immerhin die Info dass E-Autos bei
Brand deutlich unterrepräsentiert sein
aber immer noch keine genauen Zahlen
egal wo wir suchen außer ein eine Zahl
wird überall im Internet zitiert ein
amerikanischer Versicherungs Berater
gibt an dass E-Autos um den Faktor 60
seltener brennen als Verbrenner es
klingt erstmal toll zumindest für
E-Autos aber damit gibt es gleich
mehrere Probleme wir wollten euch den
Grundkurs Statistik ersparen darum
findet ihr eine ausgiebige Erklärung
unten in den Kommentaren hier kommt
jetzt die Kurzfassung erstens die
Statistik rechnet Verkaufszahlen aus
einem Jahr hoch statt auf die
bestandsflotte zu schauen also die Autos
die gerade unterwegs sind das verzerrt
das Bild natürlich vermutlich zu Gunsten
der E-Autos weil weil ihr Anteil gerade
stark steigt zweitens die Herkunft der
Daten ist unklar die zitierte Behörde
differenziert bei fahrzeugbrenden nicht
nach Antriebsart wir wollten also wissen
ob die die Zahlen sich einfach nur
ausgedacht haben oder nur schlecht
zitiert haben und wir haben Grund zur
Annahme dass die Verkaufsdaten aus 2018
stammen obwohl sie mit 2023 findings
überschrieben sind ihr seht die Seite
aktualisiert einfach immer die
Überschrift auf das aktuelle
Kalenderjahr aber man kann natürlich
nicht einfach alte Daten verbreiten
während man behauptet sie seien brandneu
okay das heißt die Zahl 60 würden wir
ehrlich gesagt mal stark anzweifeln denn
hier werden fehlerhafte oder zumindest
fragwürdige Statistiken immer wieder
aufgegriffen und verbreitet also schauen
wir mal woanders nach Zahlen und da
sieht es für E-Autos erstmal auch nicht
schlecht aus Teslas Fahrzeugdaten zeigen
z.B dass Teslas pro gefahrenem Kilometer
elf Mal seltener brennen als das
durchschnittsfahrzeug in den USA das
sind aber natürlich die Herstellerdaten
die immer einen gewissen bias haben
können aber Skandinavien hat keinen bias
und da gibt es heute schon einen hohen
E-Auto Anteil und nach den Daten aus
Schweden und Norwegen brennen E-Autos
und hybride deutlich seltener in
Schweden liegen die Werte der letzten 5
Jahre im Bereich vom Faktor 8 bis Zeh
mal seltener und in Norwegen branden
E-Autos fünfm seltener und 2022 sogar
fast sieben Mal seltener auch dazu haben
wir euch unsere Recherchen im
angepinnten Kommentar zusammengefasst
und zu all diesen Daten muss man
natürlich fairerweise sagen e-Autos sind
natürlich tendenziell neuere Autos
welchen Einfluss die batteriealterung
auf die Brandgefahr hat das kann man
leider aktuell noch nicht genau sagen
okay was nehmen wir aus all dem mit aus
Deutschland gibt es leider noch keine
belastbaren Daten aber es gibt gute
Hinweise z.B aus Skandinavien die zeigen
dass E-Autos bisher deutlich seltener
brennen und das bringt uns zu der großen
Frage warum fangen Autos eigentlich
überhaupt
anzubrennen tatsächlich ist der Grund
für einen Brand nämlich nur in seltenen
Fällen direkt direkt ein Unfall und bei
crash test schneiden E-Autos echt gut ab
die genauen Ursachen werden leider
statistisch nicht erfasst das macht es
natürlich schwierig das genau zu sagen
trotzdem wollen wir das jetzt mal
versuchen wenn wir über E-Auto brende
sprechen müssen wir aber erstmal
zwischen fahrzeugbrenden und
batteriebrennen unterscheiden denn
letzteres also dass wirklich die große
Batterie im Boden des E-Autos brennt ist
laut eines Experten viel seltener der
Fall aber für viele ist
e-autobrand ja synonym mit batteriebrand
und genau darum schauen wir uns jetzt
die batteriebrände mal genauer an wir
wissen dass eine Batterie leichter
brennt je mehr sie geladen ist und dass
es eine zusätzliche Belastung geben muss
für die sie nicht ausgelegt ist das kann
thermisch z.B durch Feuer von außen
elektrisch Überladung oder Tiefentladung
oder mechanisch z.B durch Verbiegen
passieren aber es gibt verschiedene
Schutzmechanismen um einen batteriebrand
zu verhindern z.B das
batterianagementystem oder das Gehäuse
wenn aber eines dieser Systeme versagt
kann es zu einem sogenannten thermal
runaway oder thermischen durchgehen
kommen das ist ein Phänomen bei dem es
im Inneren einer Zelle zu einem
unkontrollierbaren Temperaturanstieg
kommt dann Gast die Batterie aus sie
gibt potenziell brennbare giftige Gase
ab und wenn es zu heiß wird kann sich
dieses Gemisch entzünden was wiederum
dann die nächste Zelle überhitzt dabei
zersetzt sich die Katode und setzt
Sauerstoff frei das heißt so ein Brand
lässt sich nicht ersticken kann man
sowas dann überhaupt
löschen das haben wir dr Rolf Erbe von
der Berliner Feuerwehr gefragt denn er
beschäftigt sich schon seit Jahren mit
e-aut brennen brennende Fahrzeuge werden
von den Feuerwehren immer in der
gleichen Taktik gelöscht wir wissen in
den seltensten Fällen bei der
Alarmierung um was für ein Antrieb es
sich handelt von daher gehen wir erstmal
grundsätzlich mit Wasser vor wenn
Flüssigkeiten brennen dann müssen wir
auch mit schaumen vorgehen und bei
Elektrofahrzeugen brauchen wir erstmal
nur Wasser wir müssen dann schauen ist
die Batterie betroffen in den seltensten
Fällen brennt auch die Batterie okay ein
brennendes Auto ist erstmal ein
brennendes Auto und es macht für die
Feuerwehr keinen großen Unterschied ob
das ein E-Auto oder ein Verbrenner ist
aber selbst wenn die Batterie brennt
wird mit Wasser gelöscht das Wasser kann
durch die Kühlung den thermal runaway
aufhalten oft heißt es dass man sehr
viel Wasser braucht das liegt daran dass
ja normalerweise einfach kein Wasser in
die Batterie kommen soll um den
batteriebrand zu löschen muss aber
Wasser hinein manchmal werden Autos
deshalb geflutet warum das aber oft
nicht sinnvoll ist dazu kommen wir
gleich man kann den Wasserverbrauch aber
auch deutlich reduzieren indem man das
Auto auf die Seite gippt und so
gezielter an die Batterie herangeht hm
hochvoltanlagen und Wasser viele haben
hier ja Angst vor einem elektrischen
Schlag die Angst ist unbegründet ein
elektrischer Schar ist fast
ausgeschlossen wir haben kein geerdetes
System das heißt wir müssen immer beide
Pole der Batterie irgendwie berühren
oder in Berührung kommen und wenn wir
auch viel Wasser darauf geben äh der
Strom nimmt den Weg des des geringsten
Widerstandes dann würde ja der Strom
durch das Wasser fließen und nicht
irgendwo durch den Menschen was
eigentlich sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist und auch eine Gefährdung für
erersthelfer ist so gut wie
ausgeschlossen bei einem Unfall wird die
Batterie übrigens auch abgeschaltet und
selbst für den Fall dass das nicht
klappt kann die Feuerwehr die Verbindung
manuell trennen gut was heißt das jetzt
insgesamt für die Feuerwehr brenne von
Elektrofahrzeugen sind für die Feuerwehr
noch die Ausnahme sie brennen auch
deutlich seltener als herkömmliche
Verbrenner das sagen die ersten statis
das heißt
es ist letztlich ein Brand wie der
andere auch den wir löschen wir können
löschen wir haben aber ja noch keine
Erfahrung muss man sagen die Feuerwehren
Leben von Erfahrung und wir müssen das
erstmal sammeln bisher jedenfalls gibt
es keine Erkenntnisse dass brennende von
Elektrofahrzeugen irgendwelche Probleme
für Feuerwehren darstellen okay da habt
ihr es Feuerwehren können E-Autos
löschen ein elektrischer Schlag ist
extrem unwahrscheinlich und die
Einsatzkräfte sind vorbereitet aber über
eine Gefahr beim Löschen haben wir noch
nicht gesprochen wenn ein Auto brennt
werden giftige Stoffe freigesetzt und
die sind danach in der Luft und im
Löschwasser und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten Punkt wie giftig sind
E-Autos fangen wir dafür mal direkt beim
Brand an bei e-Autos sind im Brandrauch
mehr Fluorwasserstoff aus dem giftige
Flusssäure entstehen kann und einige
Metalle enthalten als beim Verbrenner
aber man muss sich bewusst machen dass
kein Autobrand gut für die Umwelt oder
die Lunge ist und dass Rauchgase immer
gefährlich sind um tatsächlich eine
tödliche Dosis Fluor wasasserstoff aus
dem Rauch über die Haut aufzunehmen
müsste man selbst nackt 2 bis 14 Stunden
lang im Rauch stehen und ich bin zwar
kein echter Doktor aber bitte glaubt mir
wenn ich euch sage dass ich das nicht
empfehle nach dem Brand haben wir ein
gelöschtes E-Auto von dem dann noch mehr
oder weniger viel übrig ist ein
Entsorger holt das Wrack ab allerdings
kann sich die Batterie noch mehrere Tage
nach dem Brand wieder entzünden und um
das zu verhindern werden die die Autos
manchmal vorsorglich versenkt und stehen
dann in einem Container beim Recycler
die DGUV empfiehlt das aber nur im
Ausnahmefall weil der Aufwand einfach
riesig ist das Wasser muss von einem
Entsorger abgeholt und teuer aufbereitet
werden laut dem Recycling Unternehmen
mit dem wir für dieses Video gesprochen
haben wurden in den letzten Jahren auch
schon unnötigerweise Autos geflutet
obwohl die Batterie gar nicht die
Gefahrenquelle war wie gesagt
batteriebrände sind gar nicht so oft der
Fall und das führt uns zu einer Option
über die wir noch gar nicht gesprochen
haben
kontrolliert abbrennen lassen im
Endeffekt entstehen dann auch weniger
Schadstoffe durch die hohen Temperaturen
verbrennt sehr viel und wenn wir wenig
Wasser oder auch gar kein Wasser
einsetzen dann haben wir auch keine
Kontaminationsgefahr also das
Verunreinigung in den Boden eindringen
und wie geht es weiter wenn noch etwas
von der Batterie übrig ist bei den
Recyclern werden die Batteriezellen
sortiert auseinander genommen und
recycelt dafür müssen die Werkstätten
quarantäneplätze und Arbeitsplätze für
Fahrzeuge und Batterien einrichten und
gegeben falls luftfiltersysteme
installieren das kostet natürlich alles
Geld ist aber an sich machbar und da
kommen wir zur letzten Frage wieso
denken dann immer noch so viele Menschen
dass E-Autos super häufig brennen und
was kann man dagegen
[Musik]
tun na ja um die erste Frage zu
beantworten Posts im Internet sind
manchmal auch einfach Fake und E-Autos
werden oft als Brandursache vermutet z.B
im Fall der freemental Highway die über
3700 Autos geladen hatte davon ca 500
E-Autos dabei ist die Brandursache bis
heute unbekannt und die E-Autos sind
alle scheinbar in gutem Zustand wie
sollen die also den Brand ausgelöst
haben um E-Autos noch sicherer zu machen
gibt es verschiedene Ideen zwei
Akkutypen die deutlich weniger
risikobergen sind heute schon auf dem
Markt Natrium Ionen und LFP Zellen beide
haben aber eine geringere Energiedichte
als die heute üblichen Batterien eine
weitere Idee ist eine Art Frühwarnsystem
das die Gesundheit der einzelnen Zellen
m und schon Wochen vor einem internen
Kurzschluss auf Schädigungen im Akku
hinweisen soll und es gibt noch viel
weitere Forschung auf die wir hier
leider nicht im Detail eingehen können
und bevor wir zu meiner eigenen Meinung
kommen E-Autos brennen zwar seltener
aber ein erhöhtes Risiko besteht dennoch
beim Laden wer sein Auto nämlich über
die normale Haushaltssteckdose lädt der
riskiert dass durch veraltete
Kontaktstellen auf Seiten des Hauses ein
zu hoher elektrischer Widerstand
entsteht und dieser kann dann einen
Brand auslösen deswegen empfehlen alle
von der Feuerwehr über den ADAC bis hin
zu Versicherern eine gesicherte Wallbox
und eine besonders sichere und smarte
Lösung bietet ztech an die ztec Go
Wallbox ist gerade mal so groß wie ein
iPad liefert dafür aber bis zu 22 kW und
wurde in Norwegen schon zum
sicherheitstestsieger auserkoren aber
auch hier in Deutschland wurde ztech go
erfolgreich vom TV auf Herz und Nieren
geprüft außerdem ist sie echt schick und
lässt sich echt leicht installieren
ausschlaggebend für meine Empfehlung ist
aber dass die warbox von ztech in
Verbindung mit tibber genutzt werden
kann und Tiber ist ein besonders smarter
Ökostromanbieter dem es gelungen ist den
echten Strompreis der gerade an der
Strombörse gehandelt wird an seine
Nutzer weiterzugeben das bedeutet dass
ihr euer E-Auto in der Regel mittags und
nachts super günstig laden könnt und mit
tibbas Smart charging Funktion geht das
sogar voll automatisch ohne lästiges
Micromanagement und weil die ztech Go
Wallbox mit tibba Hand in Hand geht
bekommt ihr sie auch im tibber Store und
das ist wichtig denn mit unserem code
Watson bekommt ihr bei eurer
tibberanmeldung direkt einen 50 €
storgutschein das macht ztech und Tiber
nicht nur zu einer smarten und sicheren
Lösung sondern auch zu einer
[Musik]
kostengünstigen okay was nehmen wir
jetzt mit erstens e-Autos sind sicherer
beim Blick auf die Zahlen sieht man dass
E-Autos deutlich seltener brennen als
Verbrenner die bränd werden natürlich
zunehmen aber vor allem weil mehr
E-Autos auf den Straßen unterwegs sein
werden und zweitens Feuerwehren können
E-Autos löschen aber die Frage ist oft
ob es nicht vielleicht sogar sinnvoller
ist ein Auto einfach ausbrennen zu
lassen wir überlegen übrigens gerade ob
wir noch ein extra Video mit dem
feuerwärmer machen weil er uns wirklich
mega viele spannende Dinge erklärt hat
wenn ihr euch das gerne angucken würdet
dann schreibt uns das gerne mal unten in
die Kommentare das nächste Mal wenn
jemand beim Familienessen anfängt über
brennende E-Autos zu sprechen bist du
jetzt vorbereitet schick ihm gerne
dieses Video hier ansonsten guten
Appetit und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedrick